brendan schwab harassed for not wearing
a mask on a bike trail
oh dude you would have been so upset
today why
pablo because you realize you were doing
a show with a literal [ __ ]
which one of them i was talking to both
it's like that spider-man meme was
pointing at the other spider-man
on the trail like he always is yeah i'm
turf right back in my home turf drove to
san diego yesterday that's my home turf
going and i'm i mean i'm i'm 20 miles
out from my house so it's i mean it's
rattlesnake territory yeah and i'm i
have my i listen to music while i ride
my bike
and i see a couple on horses
wow couple and horses wow what was wow
about that i don't know
people ride horses sometimes dude he
said it like he saw two people riding
unicorns
yes like yo b i saw like two super
mutants from fallout and they were
riding uh unicorns that would get a wow
really where is that at that's wild
some deep dirt brick flies his pants
look like i'm like i'm suffocating and i
can't breathe a little people just start
saying dumb [ __ ] in the chat because
brendan's on screen
pecker 29 says snakes are bendy
this is like you see brendan on screen
and you're inspired to say the stupidest
[ __ ] that comes to your brain
snakes are bendy
[Laughter]
see we're ending on a high note this is
great the world's gonna end at least we
can make fun of this [ __ ] idiot capri
pants right i mean there's that you're
not gonna take that from me when i when
i'm in the fema camps i can have the
memories of mocking this overtanned
idiot
which one
that's a good point as well
these over candidates
right big horses yeah and i was like i
caught my attention and i can see she's
going like this at me yelling yeah and
i'm like oh maybe they need he's lying
they're going he's making up a story
this is a lie they're moving through a
lot of booze like this yeah it's always
a different it's like they're moving
through it's not just like the same
bottles
he's lying by the way of course he is
everything he says is a lie he'd help or
maybe they're maybe there's a giant
rattlesnake up thing so you mean to tell
me royce that the guy who said that
ufc's leading doctor oh he talked her
like this ha ha hero
is a liar you mean to tell me that guy
would lie yes
or maybe there maybe there's a giant
rattlesnake up thing so i go excuse me
and this lady goes where the [ __ ] is
your mask
where the [ __ ] is your [ __ ] man she
didn't say that there's no way that
happened yeah there's no way nobody
believes you brendan
you're you're too being good at shape
for somebody to say some [ __ ] like that
to you they'll try that [ __ ] on like you
know
they pick and choose who they say
probably probably about art about my age
i almost said our age
[Laughter]
okay you know what i'm sorry i hate to
admit this
when i have to begrudgingly admit
something but that was actually that was
funny that was actually kind of funny
god damn it i had to admit that
i don't like this
don't mind
both about my age maybe a little younger
she goes where the [ __ ] your mouth
where the [ __ ] is your mouth i go excuse
me she goes where the [ __ ] is your mask
you're risking everybody out here i go
who's out here
who's out here she goes where's your
mask i go why in the world and i'm
trying not to cast that's the situation
i go why in the world would i wear a
mask out here are you after your goddamn
mind yelling at me but you did curse
she was well where's your [ __ ]
matthew
who are you talking to she's saying
where's your [ __ ] she's doing [ __ ]
math he here's what happened i love that
brian's always challenging his stories
how many times did she say you're right
she just kept saying it over and over
what'd she look like
here's what happened
he was riding his bicycle
huffy with the little tassels in the
belt
he remember those puffy he was riding
his bicycle and he's he's he's thinking
like
bro you know what would be a really good
story for the show bee
what if i like somebody i'd say like
somebody with horses like i gotta make
it realistic like i can't just say that
we're walking because like that that
doesn't sound right so like what if
there were like motorcycles now that's
too dangerous so like on horses right
and what if like they came up to me and
this is a this is how it you know when a
child makes up a story i think he was
really biking
i believe i'd go a step further i think
he saw some people on horses
that's an area where they would have
that
i think that he was riding without a
mask and i think some people on horses
that probably had masks on
i think a woman shot him for maybe half
a second a dirty look
and he knew in his
mind whole fight mad at me for not
wearing a mask or whatever and then in
his mind he filled in all that and then
she was like she was all like take the
[ __ ] mask on and i was like what
[ __ ] and then we were all like he just
kind of felt like i'm telling you that's
what happened he got a dirty look from
some woman and he was like in his brain
it was why the where the [ __ ] is your
mask
and then and then i'm like you should
you go how would i beat the [ __ ] hold on
well hold on
hey brian
calm down
he is a [ __ ] like considering the
brennan's the [ __ ] ufc fighter
brian's a [ __ ] hot head oh yeah he's
he's what if i beat the [ __ ] out of your
boyfriend so far in this made-up story
the boyfriend hasn't said anything he's
he is
he's notorious for being that way
and i have a feeling that that may have
um
brave bigot said he's a sober alcoholic
he's a [ __ ] dry drunk but he's uh
he's definitely
probably lost some get he i have a
feeling brian would have had a better
career
but i i think that he has a reputation
for being a hothead if i had to guess
well hold on and their boyfriend goes
yeah dude it's not cool and i'm like
what'd you say he was not he added oh ah
he added that
because brian just said why don't you
tell his boy why don't you say something
to his boyfriend he just ad-libbed it
right now you saw him just add that to
his story like no no but his boyfriend
did say something and i was like i'll
[ __ ] you up bro
so
he is making this story up as he goes
along brian's looking at him like he's
looking at a guy who's making this story
up as he goes along look at this freeze
frame and their boyfriend goes yeah dude
it's not cool and i'm like what'd you
say he was not cool i go what's not cool
and now they don't have mask on they
have bandanas on
and i go oh you so he ran into butch
cassidy and the sundance kid
[ __ ] jesse james and his crew were
out there [ __ ] okay corral
you [ __ ]
dumb dumbs think the bandanas help you
you think the bad dancer and as i say
this the lord upstairs go let's do a
breeze so we can see how stupid they are
breeze comes
the things blow up i go oh wow i can see
your entire face i can see your entire
face you think that's helping i see you
know what you guys should do you should
wait because there's i passed a few uh
uh bike lists on the way you none of
them are wearing masks because we're not
morons so when they come you guys should
ruin your whole day and wait here like
it's your job because nobody's paying
you the taxpayers aren't paying to do
this you guys should wait here and then
yell at the other guy's coming and as
there's tell me some uh the two guys who
has passed them i was talking when we
get to the top they come by and she goes
and where's your mask and they just
start laughing and keep running by i
said i should have done that but i i
thought you were i thought you were
warned by a snake and i settled
on all of this
i love how he can't by the way
when you tell a story like this
he did call him bikeless by the way
robert gaving in this chat did he call
him bike list he said a bicyclist
he's no but he's a breathing because
braves are sweeping the niche
um cyclist he
[Music]
this is how you can tell when somebody's
telling a [ __ ] story because he's he
can't even remember what was said he's
like and then i was all like you know
because the people aren't paying the tax
the taxpayers aren't paying you so it's
not your job but you should go pretend
like it's your job and go down there
like it's because it's not your job
though and and then i would ah and i was
was like
you don't remember that like where am i
good example years ago my buddy john in
north carolina got in a fight with some
[ __ ] tourists in carolina beach
because he was parking in his parking
space
in our apartment complex
and he kind of jerked in front of them
because they were going to try to take
his spot because everybody steals spaces
in the summertime so he jerked into that
spot and was getting out after work and
you could hear some [ __ ] redneck guy
the redneck guy was like man let's see
this is why i [ __ ] hate all these
yankees because these [ __ ] yankees
come down here and blah blah and john
was like the [ __ ] you just say to me i
[ __ ] live here [ __ ] why don't you
take your [ __ ] ass back to wallace or
wherever the [ __ ] you came from and the
guy was like
he just left or whatever you know john
relayed that story to me later he had no
problem recalling
every word verbatim of what was said
because he was you know you get fired up
and then you're like you know what this
[ __ ] said to me today and i told him
you don't [ __ ] like he's just like and
then i was like uh what did i say when i
say um that you because you're not you
should
it's not your job why don't you give
he's a [ __ ] mess trenton wade says
brendan sounds like a kid stalling for
bedtime
that's what he's doing still your
bedtime brady you gotta go to bed no i'm
gonna tell you a story about school the
other day go to bed
complete waste my time
and then the boyfriend says something
goes yeah well we're on here tomorrow
you better wear a mask i was like holy
[ __ ] i went you're serious dude he's
yeah you better wear a mask and then i
like punched a horse and i knocked him
out like it was blazing saddles
there you go dude i'm on this trail
every day i'll be back here tomorrow at
9 00 a.m i might write [ __ ] naked
just to prove a point
i you know what it is i mean brennan
please don't i hope he's telling the
truth i hope we're wrong and this was a
real story and i hope he goes bicycling
tomorrow and i hope he's bike listening
bike listening tomorrow thank you and i
hope he gets knocked the [ __ ] out by
some fruit picking five foot five
mexican that's what i hope i wanna see
on tmz brendan schaub gets knocked out
at a park by some civilian that would
make me laugh hysterically and he would
have no street cred
he gets trampled by a horse that would
be [ __ ] funny too
the horse just kicks him off of his
huffy
this just in the horse has been signed
to ufc
for two years fighting jon jones
[Laughter]
i go and how about
[Laughter]
well where's the math for your horses
you don't
oh you don't care about animals oh my
god you know you know your horse can get
it
you can't
your horse can't get cove at 19. when is
the horse ever been infected i don't
know if divorces got in corota virus you
know what i hate to ask this question
because i know it's just going to
frustrate you but royce is he [ __ ]
yes okay
why are you asking that of course he's
[ __ ] is this man [ __ ]
she was annoying [ __ ] okay that's the
stupid thing ah you didn't know horses
can get it and they can't have you
looked it up horses can get it bring
that up to
also he argues like a child
demonic terrorist says he's a child yeah
he argues like a child
there is a equine equine coronavirus but
it is different it's not covered then
human coronavirus well yeah there's a
cova virus there there's there is
something in the corona family of
viruses for everyone yes it's fun for
the whole family but
that's what i meant covet 19 it's like
you can't you a human can't give a horse
coronavirus the there it's called equine
coronavirus and it's been around since
2017. it is a different kind of
coronavirus they just say brave pick it
in the chat riots in the street can
horses get it that's what you're typing
into google right now can horses get a
coronavirus
i know
so justice
i really before i die i gotta know if
horses can get this we need to know we
can't die not knowing no
mike
we must know
if horses can get carbon virus
you don't know horse can you like oh oh
and i go bubba you guys watch cnn you've
been watching cnn you're scared straight
this is the first time leaving the house
this first time leaving the house you
guys have no idea no way you wear mass
except for you [ __ ] so you you're
still fighting with these people on
horses
yeah none of this happened by the way no
i know but in his make-believe what i'm
saying even in a [ __ ] made-up story
you're stretching it out too these kind
of things don't if if if a loud
disagreement goes that long it'll come
to blows by that point you're not just
gonna keep yelling like this is so
[ __ ] you just wanted to stand there
and debate the finer points of the
coronavirus and and transmitting it to
horses
for a half hour this is how i would have
done it right let's say i'm riding a
black royce you'll be a lady and go you
know hey where's your mask
so i'm riding past
are you not gonna do the thing
am i the guy on the bike no i'm the guy
on the bike i'm okay i'm the guy on the
horse hey why aren't you wearing your
mask you stupid [ __ ] shut up
that's the end of it keep pedaling it's
that simple i've done this many times in
my life how many times in your life have
you been out about somebody tries to
shame me for something
it goes shut up
just go on about your day done that a
thousand times in my life shut the [ __ ]
up and you just and when they go no but
you're not you just keep walking away
you don't keep going you shut